it wasn't like my first time trying like
i had been trying to be a performer you
know
like for a year i'd been traveling to
random colleges playing in cafeterias
like doing that thankless work that
you're like this is literally going
nowhere and you know i remember like
sleeping in my car one time just being
like this is so lonely like i just don't
know how much longer i can do this i've
done so much therapy i do all this you
speak the therapist language i do i've
done everything from like energy work to
oh all of it talk therapy to emdr to
neuro-linguistic programming like i do
i've done all of it because i have i
mean in my background it's like abc
after school special right i've got like
sexual abuse and addiction recovery and
you know a very public marriage ending
in divorce that when my child was only
one like there's a lot i got a lot to
unpack
i was in a fight on the basketball court
because everything i was
so used to
when things weren't going my way
reacting negatively
with anger because i didn't know how to
communicate my emotions
i didn't know how to be yeah we hadn't
practiced it express how i feel
because in school it was acceptable to
when someone upset you to fight them or
to slam a locker and be angry it was
acceptable because that was kind of the
behavior that you expected from someone
like that like a young boy
because every time i tried to express my
emotions i was made fun of and laughed
at and called weak it taught me to never
build a home in someone else it taught
me that i needed to start building a
home within myself
it taught me
i would say the most important lesson it
taught me is
you know the feeling of emptiness that
you feel when someone walks away you
know you feel like
i've given so much of myself
and i put it inside that person and
they're gone and you just feel like
you feel like you're a loose leaf in the
wind
and
she was going like
psychically
downward and all psychiatry could not
help her
all the pills and injections and nothing
out
she jumped from eight stories down that
that is not only feeling uh heartbroken
it's it squeezes the the life area the
the sense of life the purpose and
anything
it's
it's all gone it's okay you are damaged
at that moment you're lying on the
ground you don't want to uh you don't
want to stand up you don't know why you
shoot anymore and then i got a call
saying they you know they'd seen a tape
i'd posted and they wanted to a tape
what am i in like the 90s um
helping me feel relevant okay
they saw my tape um but
yeah they were like hey what you do is
really interesting we'd love for you to
come audition and i was like
this is it all that hard work this is my
make or break i got this i like i'm
gonna kill this and i like worked so
hard and practiced for months
and i went through that first audition
and made it
got to the second phase made it through
and i kept making it all the way until
the quarterfinals and you would think
that that would be like a hey
i made it pretty far but instead i focus
on
instead of looking at how far i'd come
on the show being a violinist that had
never performed in front of anyone more
than like a cafeteria of people who
weren't listening you know being on
stage is like that in front of millions
of people on tv very different and so
rather than being like wow good job
linds um when i was in the quarterfinals
i got up there
i was performing and i got x in the
middle of my performance which is like
humiliating like just like they only do
that if they like hate what you're doing
it's not like oh it's okay it's like we
hated it so much that i got x and my
friend was here at the fight
who works with me now and he was like i
don't want to hang out with you anymore
whoa this is one of my best friends
college football work together
everything exactly they want to hang out
with you aggressive i was like wow my
best friend doesn't want to hang out
with me that's that's like
time to look within you know what i mean
yeah not everyone else is wrong anymore
yep it's time to look at myself
and i started saying i'm gonna shed all
this stuff i think it's hard for us to
make a change in our life unless there's
some type of breakdown and the bigger
the breakdown
the more we're able to look and say okay
what's working and what's not working
right you don't you feel like you're
you have nothing that grounds you you
don't know who you are all you're
focused on is that person
and you think
that just because they walked away with
so much of what you invested in them
that they're the only person who could
give it back to you
and that's what i
like hung on to for so long
until i realized that
that feeling of emptiness was
okay
because i really did
put so much of myself
into that person and my intention wasn't
to
feel empty my intention was
to genuinely give that person the love
that i felt towards him
and
my intention wasn't to
deplete myself
my intention was i'm investing this in
someone who i deeply care about so i can
come home at the end of the day to these
things that i'm putting there
so
that feeling of emptiness is real
and
so where do you go from there and that's
when it hit me
you know trauma
um setting boundaries re-parenting like
these are all things that i feel like
we're having a moment and maybe in part
especially the trauma because of the me
too movement you know where we're now
like talking about sexual harassment and
assault way more than we ever have as a
society and i think it's it's freeing
women to people to use their voices and
to seek the help that they need and to
talk about
you know these issues is like a shared
issue and a societal issue do you
remember the first thing that you
finally admitted to yourself out loud
that was um
maybe sort of like the
the
where the shell cracked open yeah saying
the word rape
i used to talk about my i would only say
like i i've experienced sexual abuse or
i had like i forget i mean i whitewashed
it so much
um
and the first time out loud i just said
like i was raped
i mean i still like get a little lump in
my throat saying it out loud because i
think i don't want it to be true except
it is and the more i say it the more i'm
comfortable with it and like it's just
what happened i just remember standing
there
talking to them on live tv after my
performance and just
listening to them say these things to me
that were just like so hurtful and
trying not to cry on national television
just being like and in my mind i'm like
i told every friend i've ever met to
watch tonight and to vote for me like oh
my gosh i was humiliated
um and i just i remember getting off
that stage and thinking i will never
step on stage again i can't face that
like it was horrifying and you know i
cried for hours like
you know and that feels like days and
you know finally after like a few months
the pain inside of me i wouldn't say it
turned into like i'm gonna prove them
wrong maybe a little bit but also there
was just that inner voice that became
stronger than the pain
stronger than the embarrassment became
the voice of saying
you're not done yet like and i really do
feel so much that you know i relate it
to spirituality and like my relationship
with god but i believe we all have like
some kind of an inner voice
and if you listen to it
it won't lead you astray and it gets
getting stronger and stronger and it's
just like
shoot this journey it's not done like i
need to keep trying and so i did i got
back up on stages i didn't even know
what the heck to do at this point i was
out of ideas but
just by stepping on little open mic
night stages again the opportunity found
me
not there anything i did like it's just
i kept taking the bait wherever i could
find it till i finally bit on the right
one it's really hard to change anything
we have going on bigger the breakthrough
that's it i mean
and it was kind of a perfect storm and i
started going to a lot of
workshops and got asked for coaching
from a lot of people talking to their
anyone i could talk to who i thought
could help me i would talk to i would do
their program
and that's what helped me finally start
to break down the walls it was like
opening up about all my traumas of my
past and just addressing it
acknowledging it talking to friends or
to like a therapist uh i started in like
kind of group workshops where i opened
up for the first time in 25 years about
being sexually abused wow that has to be
like pretty emotional
yeah
i was like i'm taking this to the grave
i was like no one needs to know this
because no one will love me if they knew
this about me right no one accept me i
don't think i'm a what whatever i just
made up stories
blame you everything yeah
and so when i started talking about that
i was like
and people actually accepted me for
talking about i was like wow
and i said man i don't want to be scared
of this anymore so let me do it talk
about it all the time until i'm not
scared
and then i had power over all of it well
i was going to just say you take its
power away i took my power back
from it
and listen i still get triggered every
now and then and things happen and i'm
like reactive but i'm so quick to be
like okay you're going back to a place
of scarcity a fear of insecurity yeah
and that's not who you are that's not
who you want to be because half of your
life is gone after
your separation is torn within
you are wounded a wounded animal a
wounded being inside and uh society
doesn't give a [ __ ] so you need to stand
up or
stay there or be brought
into a psychiatric asylum or a lunatic
asylum or something
no i had four children i had four
children with her she was the love of my
life i was heartbroken and had four
children with her and
they were young they needed me
so they made me survive
and the sense of going into cold water
was directly there because the the mind
keeps on running circles
painfully
you know you ask yourself why why why
directly driven from a broken heart you
get that
and the cold water makes your mind go
still
it was the only moment every day
i got so deep that i was not into
suffering
that i had a moment
where i met myself
in the depths
and hey hey ryan
nothing there can you imagine
when you are depressed and suddenly
a moment of relief a moment of sunshine
after months of clouds sunshine comes
and that that made me go every day into
the cold water you know that
the cold of your emotional being broken
is much colder than going into freezing
water
so
the freezing water made me able to see
the sun again
and that i always say that my children
make me survive the cold healed me
if i'm
really fixated on what i gave that
person then that in a way makes me
selfish because i want to take back
what i gave
instead why don't i focus on the fact
that i was the source of that love
i was the source of that respect i was
the source of that kindness that i gave
to that person that i invested in that
person that i
built a home and that person with if i
am the source
then i can recreate that yeah from
within myself
for myself moving forward why would i
beg someone to give me something back
when i am the one who had the ability to
create it in the first place why put
myself at the mercy of a recipient of
something that i created
that was the biggest realization i made